so guys my last video that was an
opinion piece was about directors and
have they forgotten how to film an
action because it seems like they have
and that was very well received by you
guys and you guys wanted me to do more
videos like that so I went to Twitter
and asked you guys your opinion on a
certain subject and that is our movie
trailers ruining movies in short yeah
every once in a while you actually get a
really good trailer that actually pumps
you up for the film without revealing an
absurd amount of plot details that you
don't need to know these are the things
that you go to a movie to be excited
about things that are supposed to
surprise you things that when you're
sitting in the theater you can sit and
go wow I didn't expect that or wow that
was a cool twist or look at that cool
little easter egg that I just noticed
these are the type of things that are
being ruined for us now in movie
trailers because the studio's want us to
get there they want us to pay to see
their film they want our butts in that
seat now you do have some people in
Hollywood who are very careful about
this keep it like Christopher Nolan or
JJ Abrams or Steven Spielberg these are
people that really relish the idea of
secrets in movies the movie-going
experience and being able to experience
something that surprises you and takes
you someplace that you weren't expecting
now the other side of this is that these
filmmakers all have enough clout to the
point where they don't have to worry as
much if people are going to actually go
to see their film because they know
people are still they made trailers that
are so intriguing without giving away
all the best parts because their films
are worth it and so many films that are
out there nowadays are being spoiled by
so many things being revealed in the
trailer here are some examples on some
of these were very highly voted by you
guys on Twitter one of the biggest ones
you guys mentioned was actually the
movie castaway now if you have not seen
castaway spoiler warning because I'm
about to discuss the ending of the film
do you know the movie castaway directed
by Robert Zemeckis starring Tom Hanks
he's on an island all by himself very
good movie in the trailer for the film
they actually had the nerve to show this
we were launched for four years
we had a funeral coffin what was in it
they literally show in the trailer that
he makes it off the island
I guess he's fine and there's nothing to
worry about I understand how it was done
I don't know how somebody did that I
don't know how anyone got away with that
it's insane
another one that was frequently
mentioned was the film Terminator
Salvation and again spoiler warning if
you have not seen Terminator Salvation a
lot of people were excited for that film
because terminator they wanted it to be
really good despite the fact that it was
directed by Mick G who generally does
mediocre bull crap but that movie was
you know some people are like okay
Christian Bale's in it this could be
good and then this is in the trailer and
then he's more cuz right you think
you're human I am human any suspense or
mystery about that character and whether
or not he was a robot was just
completely taken away by that there was
no surprise and it was all ruined
another thing that people wanted me to
discuss was the fact that some trailers
don't necessarily spoil plot points but
they miss market their film they show a
film in a trailer that looks a certain
way because they think that'll get the
most people in the audience but the film
is not exactly that way one of the
Primus examples was Drive a lot of
people watch the trailer for Drive and
thought hey this is an action movie
Drive really is not an action movie this
didn't bother me because as I watched
the trailer and salted it won Best
Picture at the Cannes Film Festival and
had that very operatic music in there
I wasn't thinking it was going to be an
action film and I knew a little bit
about Nicolas Winding reference
filmography however some people who
didn't know those things that I just
said thought they were going to go watch
transporter 4 and unfortunately for
those people they were very disappointed
by that movie and that is something
that's happening a lot lately too is
it's just really a studio that is trying
to promote a film in a certain way that
they think the audience wants to see
they are going for a demographic that
they think can make them the most money
however sometimes that demographic comes
with the movie because they were
expecting a certain thing now in the
film it isn't the way they thought it
was going to be these people are now
upset and want their money back so
what's the point if you want your movie
to make a lot of money than what you
want is good word of mouth because if
you have good word of mouth that trumps
all critics reviews ever because you go
to school and the classmates like hey
man that movie was awesome
you're going to more than likely trust
that person right in front of you then a
review you read on the Internet unless
you really do care about critics reviews
but I'm talking about the average
general public they want good
word-of-mouth
if you falsely advertised your film and
then they go to see it and that
disappoints them because it wasn't the
film they were expecting you're not
going to get that good word-of-mouth and
you're gonna make less money
how do people not connect the dots on
this it's so easy if you have a film
that a certain way market it for that
audience that you know that film is
gonna want to see and market it in the
way that it should be marketed not just
to get butts in the seats but market it
as the film that it is and don't spoil a
whole bunch of stuff now by far I'm
talking by far the biggest one that
everyone mentioned on my Twitter was the
amazing spider-man 2 and I have to agree
spoiler warning coming up for that film
if you have not seen it I'm going to
discuss certain plot details in detail
not only did that trailer spoil the
final shot of the movie by showing
spider-man swinging a sewer grate into
Rhino making you think well if that's
the how the trailer ends then there's
gonna be a fight right actually that's
just the last shot in the movie not only
did it show things like that but it
showed doc Ock's arms and vultures wings
it showed Gwen Stacy hanging in a clock
tower and spider-man spinning down a web
towards where she's hanging anyone who
ever read a comic book and their life
could have tailed well you know what I
think Gwen Stacy probably dies there's
even a shot of Peter Parker like crying
his eyes out in the trailer what would
make Peter Parker cry like that more
than likely his web-shooters didn't run
out of webbing more than likely Aunt May
didn't die in a clock tower somewhere
Gwen Stacy's probably dead
thanks Sony but it's not just those plot
points and Easter eggs that are in the
trailer there's a ton of things in that
trailer that actually aren't in the
movie scenes that are set up in the
trailer as an intriguing plot point that
aren't in the film that don't come off
as deleted scenes what they come off as
as something that was actually shot
specifically for the trailer as a way to
make you want to see the film that's not
actually in the movie now let me explain
this and I'm going to back this up with
points because you might be saying well
Chris no those are just deleted scenes
they'll be on the DVD in the blu-ray and
you may be absolutely right some of
those scenes may be on the DVD and the
blu-ray like the scene where Harry looks
at Peter and says hey Oscorp had you
under surveillance
I isn't that the question of the day not
in the movie at all have I been the DVD
but let me talk to you about a certain
scene it's in the trailer let me show
you that scene here it is what about
Peter not everyone has a happy ending
so Harry Osborn's talking to Norman
Osborn on his deathbed now remember that
scene in the movie was the first scene
we had with Harry Osborn really he's
talking to Norman he's realizing is
probably going to die they're talking
about this disease that they're both
contracting now in the trailer he says
what about Peter and Norman says not
everyone has a happy ending this makes
no sense to me you know why because in
the movie during that scene where Harry
is talking to Norman Harry hasn't even
seen Peter in like 10 years they don't
meet until later in the movie so why in
the world would he with a smirk on his
face ask his dad or the how Peter and
the Norman says hey not everyone has a
happy ending why would that be in the
movie then because it wouldn't be in the
movie then he has no idea where Peter is
he hasn't seen him in like a decade that
scene I think was specifically shot for
the trailer to make it seem like Harry
and Norman we're gonna team up against
Peter that's the only way that could
make sense to me and that makes me
really pissed off
hey Sony what the hell man is it enough
that every product in the film has to be
Sony a product placement of some kind
and the fact in the beginning of the
movie Richard Parker's on an airplane
apparently 14 years ago but he has Wi-Fi
on his sony vaio computer that didn't
exist 14 years ago sorry I'm on a
tangent here movie trailers are ruining
movies and it comes so rarely nowadays a
we get to see a trailer that actually
lives up to the film that actually
promotes in the way it should be without
spoiling a whole bunch of things and the
sad part is when a trailer is released
that is intriguing but doesn't spoil a
lot of plot points people act very
disappointed about it remember the
teaser for interstellar a lot of people
were really mad that didn't really show
that much I was like wow I'm intrigued
by this film and I don't know anything
thank you that's great I'm very happy
about this guys what are your thoughts
on the current state of movie trailers
and the way they are just over
saturating our environment to the point
where we basically see the entire film
before we even pay to see it
I'd love to know
your thoughts are below and as always
thank you so much for watching guys and
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stuck my next